una larga ovación del Congreso de los
diputados español tras la que el
presidente de Colombia ha bromeado
diciendo que en 20 años de diputado en
su país nunca obtuvo una igual así
inició Gustavo Petro su discurso en
Madrid en el que con referencias a El
Quijote el presidente colombiano hizo
símiles entre la política la vida y el
cambio y habló de una nueva relación con
Europa que deje el pasado atrás sin
embargo la mayoría de sus palabras las
dedicó a la emergencia climática
asegurando que salvar la humanidad es la
misión más importante del momento y
urgió a hacer cambios o abocarnos a la
extinción el primer viaje de Petro a
Europa como presidente sigue a la que
hizo el líder de Brasil Lula da Silva a
Madrid del pasado 26 de abril su
presencia en España no ha gustado a un
sector muy conservador de exiliados
latinoamericanos reunidos en el Foro de
Madrid un grupo fundado por el partido
de ultraderecha español vox que denuncia
que estos líderes de izquierdas haber
sido elegidos en las urnas están
cometiendo crímenes contra la democracia
Petro sabe que tiene aquí a sus socios
en Sánchez en los separatistas en los
comunistas que están en el gobierno y
aprovecha ese apoyo para intentar
manipular confundir y ablandar la
opinión pública respecto a la
legitimación y el blanqueamiento que
están haciendo ahora todos los
presidentes de izquierda primero con la
tiranía de Nicolás maduro y después con
las otras tiranías del continente yo
creo que esto es una estrategia macabra
de todos ellos que están bien
organizados muy bien organizados para
conquistar con su ideología y con su
lineamiento todo iberoamérica tras
reunirse con el rey Felipe vi y recibir
la llave de oro de la villa de Madrid de
mano del alcalde de la capital española
la visita de estado de Gustavo Petro
culminará el jueves con una reunión
bilateral con el presidente del gobierno
español Pedro Sánchez es la única visita
de este nivel que ofrecerá á España en